avoid an attachment is
when we feel
emotionally threatened in a relationship
or we feel insecure that our impulse is
to distance our impulse is to keep
somebody at an arm's length
and this can show up in a lot of
different ways
it can show up in literally this feeling
of uh you know we got in a fight oh now
i'm gonna go out with my friends you
know i'm just gonna like
vacate this argument and i'm just gonna
leave
uh but it can also show up uh in
techniques like sometimes grand romantic
gestures
actually are a way of not being
authentically intimate by consuming time
with
uh grand acts of romance opposed to
having a real emotional authentic
vulnerability instead of just being like
here i am let's meet on this level it's
like performing sure am i enough right
here just like this something simple you
know
yeah and it comes from that same place
of am i lovable
well i don't know if i am so i'm gonna
do these big things to kind of
look over here yeah
and then anxious attachment style is
when there's conflict of this i want to
bring you closer um and i'm going to try
to pull you as close as i can
and
but with it with anxiety on it because
there's fear of
if i don't have you at a certain uh
level of intimacy perhaps this is not
going to last and so it is uh fear-based
and more clinging and that's what i that
was what i had to work through adam was
more avoidant i think it's like 15 of
the population has secure attachments so
this is not like an uncommon thing it's
great mentally in our society uh i think
most people are screwed up yeah
absolutely so it's really really common
so don't feel bad if you identify with
one of these categories uh you know i
had my own avoiding attachment stuff to
work through elisa had her anxious
attachment stuff to work through and
like we said we're not supposed to be
perfect when we come to relationship in
fact sometimes it's i've seen it can be
a more miraculous healing journey when
you come to relationship with all your
baggage because then if you really heal
that with a person
then you build such a deep level of
trust with that person yeah we have been
through it like especially in the
beginning of our relationship and
normally um those two styles attract
each other where you'll have somebody's
avoidance and someone who's anxious and
then you just have
the anxious person
you know wrestling them down pulling
them in questioning them getting more
neurotic getting analytical and then the
avoidant person's going away and then
withdrawing and coming back and it
becomes this kind of can't live with you
can't live without you sometimes
passionate kind of like projective ex
can be explosive relationship and um
they activate each other right they like
feed into each other those two styles
and if it's unconscious it's a really
bad situation if it's conscious it's an
opportunity it's like oh look this is
actually kind of awesome because it's so
at the surface
all those feelings that there's a lot of
potential for healing but it takes
a certain type of the reason our first
we go on in the book about a healthy ego
is because we don't speak of ego more
yogically of annihilate the ego get rid
of the ego we're coming more
psychologically to that idea of you need
a healthy ego an ego can be good or bad
depending if it's conscious or
unconscious but a healthy ego is capable
of
staying when it's uncomfortable
so you need someone and that's the human
part of holy and human of like assessing
in your relationship is this person
capable
of handling that emotional dissonance
when those old wounds surface and then
sitting through it because if they can
sit through it takes courage and it
takes persistence and it takes being
conscious of what's happening if you're
not conscious then it's just like this
relationship sucks i'm not just you're
not what i want i'm not getting what i
need from you because they're
uncomfortable but if it's conscious
around
actually i really want you
and because of that desire
i'm annoyed because i'm feeling all my
old family stuff and my body
and i so i feel terrified and i if they
can it's like one can you identify
those feelings which is not always that
sounds simple people think like
identifying feelings like yeah of course
you know how you feel but honestly most
people have no idea how they feel when i
used to work in rehabs that was so
shocking to me we had a feeling chart
similar to the one like we put in this
book
we'd pass it around and be like pick
three feelings that you're feeling right
now off this chart and and you'd think
that'd be so basic and me who had been
through
pacific or graduate institute jungian
training like you think i would be able
to do that pretty well and i remember
getting handed the feeling chart and
being like
well like how
because the idea of how we think we're
feeling is usually different than what's
actually happening in our body in the
moment so it's coming into the present
moment
which takes kind of trauma
withdrawing deprogramming to do that
and then identifying what am i and
usually it can be mixed you can be like
excited and nervous
or
you know inspired and terrified so it's
starting to identify
those places and then bringing love and
healing to the places that need
attention
within that
so
in a relationship there's so much going
on i see like we're like these universes
and we can't collide together and then
you have like a third universe that's
created by these two universes
and it's like what's that universe about
in terms of the soul lessons and
contracts and what is going on and also
this might be out there for some people
but we believe it's like a soul journey
so it's also not just this lifetime
it's broadening right to like
and whether you believe that or not it's
just
there's a lot going on
and so so it's kind of like getting
aware of
like well what one thing i was gonna say
was uh one of the reasons we chose the
title holy love was because we wanted to
move away from this idea that love is
simply a just an emotion
and that love is actually a process so
one way i think people see relationships
is like love is something that you are
going to go get in a relationship
and so you
crave a relationship because you want
that feeling and then when you have your
first conflict are disappointed about
something with your partner then you're
like well i didn't get that feeling so
i'm out i guess that's not love
are
or i'm doing something wrong or i'm
unlovable but if we see love as a
process that's happening to us
because we see love as a
moment-to-moment thing the way that love
is showing up right now in this moment
for us for this conversation is
different than it's going to show up 30
minutes later so you have to stay tuned
to what love is you can't predict you
can't put any rules on how love should
act
you have to be open to it receiving the
intuitive information
uh from love so in that way we really
see love as a spiritual
journey yeah that makes me think of a
statement that i've heard recently that
i thought and i think it was jordan
peterson who said it that um
relationships you could even maybe even
put the word love instead of it right um
is a decision not a discovery
and that there's i think there's some
truth there in that you know
you know you you
you have this
situation with a person and and the
relationship is a decision you're like
okay yeah like i'm all in it's not just
sort of like let's just see how you act
tomorrow it's like no
and so the hard part is is like how do
we find ourselves in sync with the right
person so that we don't make a bad
decision i think we would also say i
mean i like that what you're saying and
i totally agree with that and i would
say for us
and it's kind of semantics but for us i
think love is both of those things it's
a dece you make the decision
so that then you're discovering like a
whole other
realm
yeah of love that's a potential once
you're consistent and made that real
committed decision
because i'm discovering stuff every
moment with adam right but it's not it's
not like discovering if i want to be
here right it's more it's more um
through
our
trust and through those decisions we
made when it was hard when we wanted to
leave and we had arguments in the
beginning when we were working on our
attachment stuff that like adam would i
remember once he said to me like
i want it because he used to fish and go
up to alaska and you know do this like
manly thing off by himself and i
remember when he was like i think i want
to go to alaska and just like get out of
here but like i can't even leave you
because i know if i'm like alone in a
fishing boat in alaska like you're still
gonna be there with me like it was like
he was realizing that there was no
getting away
from the love i would say that's
actually the moment i i healed my
avoiding attachment or a piece of it was
we had gotten in an argument and i had
that emotional impulse to run right i
was like i want out like and it wasn't
because of anything specific it was
because my trauma was up you know my my
inner child wounds from when i was
little
and so that was activated but then this
feeling of elisa had touched something
true in me
and i knew that
if i ran if i had left her
that i would almost be haunted by
her experience because it would be like
oh there was this thing that was true
that i missed out on and so i realized
in that moment that there was no escape
in a way it was the wisdom of no escape
of one and i think you know we all talk
about how we want love we're all like we
want love we want the perfect
relationship but what most people don't
realize is that love reveals all of our
wounds love brings up all the places we
feel like we're not loved and where we
have self beliefs that we're not loved
so it's really hard but to get to your
question about how do you know it's that
person right how do you know that this
is somebody that's worth investing in
and worth uh building that trust to go
through all the wounds with
we have a huge section of our book
dedicated to trying to recognize who is
a soul match for you and
so that is taking a lot you know
all our dating websites focus on
egoic traits for making matches for
people they're like oh what are your
hobbies what's your personality type
what you know what's your religion
there's what do you think you want
so there's it's based off of all of uh
egoic
traits and characteristics and and not
to dismiss those because those are
important too but what we lack i think
as a culture is being able to
inherently
sense
somebody's essence
of who they are on an energetic level so
not who they are based on their actions
or their words
uh but who they are as a soul
so we really see one uh metaphor we use
in the book is it's like complementary
colors like you can be with somebody and
your color feels less vibrant and it
kind of loses its hue
but if you're with a soul that matches
you usually have a feeling of more life
force of more energy
and so we we bring it to a somatic level
of really trying to deprogram your
beliefs of what you think a relationship
should be and see if you can get into a
uh emotionally aware place of becoming
aware of that biofeedback from another
person somatic just means how it feels
in your body how does that feel and um
we have a whole chapter on tough love
because it's not sometimes loving the
loving information is to leave
because sometimes
and and i think that's really hard
sometimes for people because the idea of
being spiritual or compassionate is kind
of like sometimes people interpret that
as i'll enable anything i'll stay even
positive
yeah and i'll just like not necessarily
see
what's happening but if something's
really toxic or really unhealthy then
you have to kind of listen to love about
not enabling or or potentially leaving
but i think we're so realistic about
where the human is capable because even
if you have some wonderful soul
connection if in that lifetime that
person is
because of the nature of their trauma
and if they're also just not going to
care about healing basically right like
if they have the trauma and they don't
want to do the work
you can only get so far yeah it is a we
have this personal accountability of
like are we going to choose because it's
hard sometimes to stay and open to love
when your stuff's triggered so it's kind
of like also being realistic with like
is this person capable of hanging
when the stuff gets tough or are they
going to project out and be like well
maybe it's just you
yeah because they could only go so far
then in that case yeah you can only go
as far as your healing essentially and
you know
if you can't make peace with yourself
it's hard to make peace with the other
person
[Music]
you